[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia se cumplen 30 años del fin del
apartheid en sudáfrica un sistema
político y social que le permitió a una
minoría blanca gobernar de forma
discriminatoria y durante 42 años sobre
una mayoría de afros indios y mestizos
el 17 de junio de 1991 las tres cámaras
del parlamento sudafricano la blanca la
mestiza y la india derogaron la última
de las leyes que sostenía el compendio
jurídico del apartheid que los recién
nacidos fueron clasificados por razas de
esta forma se puso fin a cuatro décadas
de segregación racial institucionalizada
en sudáfrica un racismo que venía de
siglos atrás pero que legalmente tuvo
sus orígenes en 1902 tras el tratado de
paz entre británicos y afrikáner es
antiguos colonos neerlandeses quienes
sentaron la premisa de que el hombre
blanco debe ser siempre el amo por tanto
su primero en el derecho a voto de los
negros y 11
años más tarde en 1913 legalizaron la
figura del black land act una ley por la
cual se les podía despojar de sus
tierras eran los mismos años en que
había sido fundado el congreso nacional
africano el partido político de la etnia
xhosa que desde 1912 luchaba por
restituir el derecho al voto de los
africanos negros y mestizos
justamente hace 30 años en 1991 nelson
mandela tomó las riendas del congreso
nacional africano luego de que un año
antes el por entonces presidente
frederik de klerk lo hubiese liberado de
los 27 años de prisión que pagó por
supuestamente haber conspirado para
derrocar al gobierno con mándela libre y
presidiendo el congreso nacional
africano él aparte tenía sentenciado su
final el 17 de marzo de 1992
los sudafricanos votaron masivamente un
referendo en contra de la parte de iu a
favor de que el partido de mandela
pudiera tener el derecho de competir en
una carrera presidencial y así fue
congreso nacional africano considerado
como un paria desde 1960 pudo legalmente
aspirar a ser parte de unas elecciones
democráticas este hecho como el fin del
desmantelamiento del apartheid le
valieron a nelson mandela y frederik
declaró el premio nobel de paz en 1993
en 1994 nelson mandela llegó a ser el
primer presidente negro de sudáfrica
gracias al voto de millones de
sudafricanos entre el 26 y el 29 de
abril de ese mismo año que le apostaron
a una política de reconciliación
nacional de modo que mándela instauró
entre 1996 y 1999 la comisión
sudafricana de la verdad y la
reconciliación un estrado para apaciguar
los resentimientos derivados de 42 años
de apartheid y tres siglos de
discriminación racial la segregación
racial en sudáfrica fue ampliamente
practicada desde el asentamiento de las
primeras colonias neerlandesas en el
cabo de buena esperanza a mediados del
siglo
conforme fueron pasando los años se
generó un fenómeno de inmigración en los
actuales sudáfrica y namibia de colonos
europeos en su mayoría de los países
bajos estos inmigrantes se
autodenominaron afrikaners un pueblo
blanco sustentado en la economía
agrícola con su propia lengua afrikaans
derivado del neerlandés su asentamiento
no habría sido posible de no haber
batallado intensamente contra los
bantúes pueblos nativos del sur de
áfrica y contra los británicos uno de
los principales colonizadores del
continente desde 1948 los afrikaners se
instalaron oficialmente en el poder
gracias a la victoria de su partido el
partido nacional casi de inmediato este
partido privilegio el nacionalismo de su
gente es decir la segregación racial
para darle legitimidad a esta
segregación conocida como apartheid que
en lengua afrikáans traduce separación
legislaron sobre la base del color de
piel
construyeron barrios exclusivamente para
los blancos otros para los negros el
sistema de autobuses tenía no solo
silletería sino paradas de exclusividad
para los blancos los negros tenían sus
propias universidades y hospitales todos
de peor calidad con respecto a las de
los blancos incluso había playas para
los unos y para los otros y para que no
hubiera lugar a mezclas quedó prohibido
el sexo y el matrimonio interracial años
más tarde tras el fenómeno de
inmigración de la clase trabajadora de
india y de pakistán el sistema de la
parte incluyó la raza de los asiáticos
en total el partido nacional afrikáner
durante los 42 años de apartheid aprobó
317 leyes para legalizar el racismo y
privilegiar a la minoría blanca que para
1988 constituía apenas el 14% de la
población estás 317 leyes fueron cayendo
una tras otra con la llegada de de klerk
al poder el último presidente blanco de
sudáfrica
acepto la realidad de su momento el fin
del socialismo con la caída del muro de
berlín la pérdida de aliados
internacionales tras la disolución de la
unión soviética la presión de las
naciones unidas por un proceso de
democratización y un sistema caduco cuya
vigencia requería de represión y muerte
desde que las leyes del apartheid fueron
derogadas hasta la última de ellas en
junio de 1991 y con el ascenso de nelson
mandela a la presidencia en 1994
sudáfrica no ha vuelto a tener
presidentes blancos ni tampoco distintos
a la afiliación política del congreso
nacional africano muchos expertos
aseguran que si bien actualmente no
existe discriminación racial sustentada
en leyes las cicatrices del racismo
social perduran y se pueden percibir en
la vida cotidiana de los sudafricanos
así concluimos hoy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]